so good afternoon everyone and welcome
to uh
a great debate of this a lovely sunny
afternoon um the bounce the crunch heat
death no not a new range of uh serials
or a set of video games these are the
current scientific theories about how
our universe will end
but
there is little
there is little consensus and the end
begins to look as deeply mysterious as
the beginning of the universe
should we conclude that there is no end
to the universe and that once in it in
existence it cannot be distinguished
or is time part of the universe and talk
of a beginning
or end mistake
or is our difficulty in being able to
frame an answer to these questions a
sign of the limitation of human
understanding
itself here today to
debate these points is stefan gillen
on my right who is a physicist at the
university of sheffield his research
focuses on how quantum physics might
change our understanding of the
beginning of the universe
chandrima ganguly is a cosmologist at
the university of cambridge
their research involves testing early
universe models and using cosmology to
constrain particle physics and on my far
left alexander franklin who is a
lecturer in philosophy at king's college
london his research explores why there
is anything other than fundamental
physics and his goal is to develop
explanations of the existence of these
special non-fundamental sciences so
as we crack on now to address these
questions what i'm going to do first is
to ask each of our speakers in turn to
answer very succinctly a simple and deep
uh question is the universe going to end
and if so how
okay can dream at first
well um as a physicist uh the way i
approach problems is
to come up with a verifiable model and
then try to test it unfortunately as a
cosmologist this becomes quite a
difficult enterprise because it's very
hard to gain direct observational and
experimental evidence
of the history and particularly the
beginning of the universe
now
the current theory of gravity which is
very well accepted is a theory of
general relativity and there has so far
been no observational experimental
evidence to go against this theory and
within this theory space and time are
seen to be uh one object and we talk
about the space-time continuum curving
based on what kind of matter we put in
it and the matter in turn moves along
the space-time curvature
so within the solutions to the equations
in general relativity we have predicted
several ends so we can have a cyclic
universe one that i'm particularly
interested in we can have a big crunch
where the universe has an explosive end
we can have a universe that expands
forever
and in fact it expands infinitely
now all of these different scenarios are
brought about by changing the matter
content that you would put in our
universe so for me to answer this
question the first thing we really need
to know is what kind of matter we put in
our universe for example
in the current day accelerated expansion
seems to be mediated by a mysterious
component called dark energy which we
don't really have a good understanding
of
the second thing is the nature of
gravity itself
so i said that i would be
working within the paradigm of general
relativity this in itself was a paradigm
shift from newtonian gravity now we know
the very beginning of the universe uh
will is probably governed by a different
paradigm from general relativity gravity
at very high energies and very small
length scales probably some kind of
paradigm of quantum gravity is needed to
explain the beginning of the universe
and then i ask perhaps we need a
completely new paradigm to explain the
very end of the future of our universe
in fact even now people think that
perhaps dark energy is not the answer to
why the universe is accelerating in this
way in its expansion and people are
doing some research into modifying the
theory of general relativity finally and
this is a slightly out there point
perhaps we need to consider that the way
we construct our theories our scientific
theories are based on mathematical and
logical form
this is the method that i choose as a
scientist but i think it's important to
highlight that it is a method and
strictly speaking philosophically sure
alex will elaborate on it may not be the
case that the future of our universe can
be explained by theories that follow
this mold
so overall my stance is that
continuing a a line of scientific
inquiry if not
helping us to converse to an answer
about the very end will at least help us
to nuance that discussion and given how
the history of science has evolved we
can at least say that by nuancing that
discretion by byproducts we end up
discovering and progressing
well human knowledge a little bit more
along the way
thank you chum dreamer
next i'll ask stefan another scientist
to give his take on the question of is
the universe going to end
right so thank you for the question it's
a very good question um i think i'll
follow on on some of the points that
chandrima made
but first of all i want to give my my
answer which is no i don't think the
universe can end
and the point i want to make is that
sort of we have within the framework of
our current theories we have different
scenarios that you might think of as the
end of the universe
because they seem sort of violent
drastic events that seem to bring the
universe to an end
but for me these are sort of more
failures of the theories themselves so i
really see these as a breakdown of the
theory that we have and the sign that we
need a better theory in in its place um
so i'd like to make um
focus on a specific example which is the
big crunch um so just to sort of explain
a bit what that means um so people i
think are familiar with the book bang as
the beginning of the universe so we
sometimes think of that as the beginning
the universe came into existence and
sort of space and time sort of started
being there at the big bang and then the
universe started expanding and of course
becoming
very big
today and so
depending on the assumptions that you
put in and chandrima already mentioned
that there are quite a few assumptions
that need to be made
you might have the reverse of that
process you might have a contraction of
the universe as a whole at some point
and then that contraction process would
sort of accelerate
and
at the very end you would have this kind
of violent event where sort of the
universe shrinks down to zero size
mathematically speaking right so
everything really ends up in this in
this point and it's quite difficult to
to describe that even with words because
we don't really know what what happens
and but if you try to do a calculation
you you calculate sort of the
temperature or the energy density
of the universe you just you know
everything goes to infinity so the
theory really just breaks down so my
take would be that this does not mean
that this is the end of the universe but
it means that the theory fails
and i would strongly advocate the need
for a quantum theory of gravity so so
the theories and models that i'm
exploring are based on that idea sort of
the the classical description of space
and time coming to an end perhaps but
being replaced by a kind of quantum
transition into something else so that's
how i would see the end rather as a
transition into something new by quantum
physics thank you stefan and uh to get a
philosopher's perspective over to alex
thanks uh so yeah so as the philosopher
probably won't surprise you my answer is
it depends and and maybe
um so is the universe going to end well
i guess we should probably be a bit more
precise about what we mean by universe
and end so um
so if we're going to ask like is the
universe going to end well let's look
around us all this stuff you know the
earth and the sun and the galaxy etc
well is that going to end then yes and
so by the universe the stuff we refer to
around us you know the earth will be
engulfed by the sun at some point and
the solar system will be sort of
swallowed into the supermassive black
hole at the center of the milky way and
you know all of this kind of stuff will
end so in that sense yes the universe
will end maybe everything will be
absorbed into black holes and those
black holes might evaporate and then
there's nothing
but
you know as a physicist we should or as
physicists together we should think
about the other kind of content so not
just this kind of structured content
but particles and fields will that end
well it looks like
consistent with the empirical empirical
data we have available it looks like
that stuff won't really end it looks
like there's just going to be a kind of
heat death everything just expands and
gets bigger and bigger and bigger until
the kind of average density goes down to
approximately zero in any particular
region of space time but that's not so
much it ends then the second question is
will it like what do we mean by end
so
um
everything the universe has two ends and
why do we say when we say is the
universe going to end why do we think
about the future one rather than the
past one if we think about the past one
then we say does the universe have an
end well the big bang seems like a kind
of end maybe there was something before
it who knows but it seems like that was
a kind of end of the universe and why
might we want to think about the
beginning the sort of the past and the
future is kind of interchangeable
well i think it might be useful to kind
of make an analogy with up and down
we used to think that sort of there was
obviously a privileged direction
obviously there's a difference between
up and down but that's just because
we're on the earth
if we imagine being an interstellar
space and the up down distinction loses
any kind of content if we imagine being
a kind of right at the sort of future
kind of end of the universe when there
are no kind of stable processes or
structures then we might well think that
there is no meaning to past and future
in such a context and so the idea that
we should really privilege the past end
rather than the future end is the real
end or the other way around i think we
should be careful about so
yes it depends thank you um
and now we're going to move on to some
specific questions and debate each of
these in turn so the first one of these
questions
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas